Do you have any guidance around
taking notes from books and lectures?
Yeah,
yeah.
No problem.
Like don't be taking
notes during the lecture.
Exactly because then you're
not listening to the lecture.
It's like listened to the lecture
and then take notes afterwards.
Now that doesn't work
for every discipline but.
But it certainly works for disciplines
like students in my lectures.
I always tell them,
don't take notes during the lecture,
listen to the damn lecture.
You can take notes afterwards because
what that does is force you to practice
remembering and then
with regards to books,
it's like read,
don't highlight,
don't underline like that.
I think that that's just rubbish.
I think it's pseudo work.
Read a couple of paragraphs or maybe
an essay or something like that.
Depending on the density of the book.
Close the book,
think about it,
write down what you're thinking,
write down what you remember but,
but,
but in the context of what you're thinking
about because that instantiates it
into your memory and
give and puts it at hand.
Like people ask me,
for example,
how it is that I can remember all the
things that I talk about extemporaneously
when I'm lecturing and the reason for
that is because I've thought them through,
you know,
I read them and I think,
oh,
okay,
well that's an interesting idea.
How does it relate to all
these other ideas that I know,
like what is it significance for this
idea and what's its significance for this
idea and do I believe it and
how might I criticize it?
So it's Kinda like I'm,
I'm attaching little memory hooks to it
in in five different ways and then I've
got it.
It's,
it's part of me and that seems
to be part of recall rather than.
So rather than recognition and recall
is the Spontaneous Act of remembering
something complex and
when you recall something,
you're actually practicing remembering
it and that's what you need to do if you
want that to be part of you.
So I would say separate out the
function of reading and note taking.
So read,
think,
write or read.
Write.
Think though,
because the last two
things are quite similar,
but don't read the book and then read
a sentence and then write down that
sentence.
That's not helpful.
You could read the sentence,
close the book,
and then reformulate the sentence
so that now it's your sentence,
man.
Then you'll remember it.
Then you'll understand it.
That works really well.